our next guests are a special duo
one of them is a lifestyle expert
entrepreneur and founder of women of
today
as well as a great wife and an amazing
mother and a philanthropist
and the other is a spunky spitfire who
happens to be
her mother-in-law please welcome camilla
alves mcconaughey and kaye
you mcconaughey i'm so good i'm so happy
to see you okay
it's very nice to see you you remember
the last time i saw you with boys on the
side
oh my gosh when your wonderful son
played the character
of abraham lincoln the police officer
yes
but i remember that voice on the side it
was it was so exciting to be on the set
you know that's what i remember because
i was kind of new to this you know and
so
i was so excited to meet you anyway and
you don't look like you've changed much
so whatever you're doing
keep it up well thank you kay i so
appreciate that
i and camilla i really
like and respect you and i was pouring
through
every corner of the women of today
website
and it's so beautifully put together
thank you for sharing that it means it
means a whole lot thank you you know
it's a project that
it started just as a passion project and
the community just kind of grew
organically it's not you know
people joke all the time you know what's
the business plan i'm like well
we don't have it the community is
telling us what they want to see
what they want to do what they want to
learn about you know the big difference
is that we're not talking to you we're
talking with you
and we get to learn from each other just
like i learned from mama
quite a lot you learn from each other is
what we
yes well also camilla i think you were
doing
lifestyle and you know stuff with your
kids
and you were putting that all out there
far before it was on trend
and i feel like you were a big pioneer
with like
kids and cooking and philanthropy and
you know design and lifestyle
and um i feel like you were very first
to the plate with all of that stuff
we did start very early on like we i was
doing those things and it's kind of
started by accident
i was doing a business and it was very
business business
and i was like you know i just need to
sh i just want to share what i love
that it's outside of keeping numbers
keeping you know
sales and all of that and it kind of
started by
accident and it was very very early on
and thank you for
uh recognizing and saying that not a lot
of people
say that so thank you i love the fact
that also
you know you and kay now are on this
journey and we get to go on that journey
because like let's face it there are
movies made about in-law
relationships yes you're absolutely
right
and some of them are not very very very
productive but we get along really well
together it took some work
testing we were testing each other well
i was saying where you were testing me i
was tested
i mean anybody was going to hang out
with my my son
i wanted to know a little bit about so
yes
yes it was a lot of testing at first but
you know what you're like throughout
this time you know she
obviously we've um have she's been
staying with us
we were keeping everybody safe during
this time yeah and i was doing all the
women of today's stuff
and i was like you know my mac you're
here you know you have so much knowledge
and do you want to be part of it and you
jumped right on it and
i did and it's a way that we get to
really connect and have fun together
during this time
really yeah see i love hearing you say
that because
i'm you know i'm really really close
with my kids family and we're really
real with each other and there's so much
humor um you know the one thing that
we've noticed from a lot of people in
the community that what they see when
they see me and my mac
you know we're very different we look
very different
right we look very different
perfect you know we sound different we
come from very different backgrounds you
know i was born and raised in brazil
mama do you want to say where are you
from the real [ __ ]
listen to this nobody really knew where
she was from into
not long ago yeah okay she was hiding
this whole time do you want to say where
you're really
well i'm from new jersey no i'm i'll
tune in pennsylvania but
who wants to be born in altoona
pennsylvania nobody
okay so you know we've noticed that you
know people really started to find
um our story inspiring just to the fact
that hey
how can two worlds get along so well how
you know the age difference she's mamak
is 88 now yes
but you know the gap is it's big between
us
and we come from very different
backgrounds and we still have this
really close bond and close relationship
and we're able to
add a lot to each other's lives but the
key
is respect you must have
respect i don't say you should or could
but you must have respect
for each other you're absolutely right i
think respect is a great
definition of love and i think
also you just you make it work
you find each other's ends you
appreciate each other's differences
you make it work you're honest you're
truthful there's humor there's affection
and by the way okay if i may come full
circle on the kind compliment you gave
me
88 and looking smoking hot
oh thank you thank you well i'm excited
to be hanging out with you guys i thank
you so much
for coming um on the show and i can't
wait to promote everything that you guys
are doing
um womenoftoday.com will be up on our
website so we can like sister out
and um you know cross-pollinate all the
goodness and um thank you guys
thank you camilla thank you right back
you